the media suggests the President Trump
is cruelly tearing children of the arms
of their illegal immigrant parents
Harvard goes racist and some leftist
columnist celebrate Father's Day by
saying fathers are unnecessary I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
all right if you have tons to get to
today I mean like there is a lot
happening and we are going to get to all
of it in just one second first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over at
filter by so I'm just gonna put this out
there I suspect that you are not sitting
around thinking about your error filters
because I mean let's face it that's not
the most interesting topic but the
reality is that you're hacking up a lung
are you feeling unhealthy at home maybe
one of the reasons is because you
haven't replaced your air filters in
forever I know that we hadn't replaced
our air filters in forever until we went
to filter by and filter by made sure
that we did and the air is just that
much better according to the Department
of Energy the most expensive utility for
most Americans is their electricity bill
makes up roughly 9% of their annual
housing expenditure this number is
aggravated depending on where you live
take California we actually get
clobbered on energy bills well adding
insult to injury the salary season has
been one of the worst further straining
your system so you can help lower all of
these bills and make the air better by
going to filter by America's leading
provider of HVAC filters for homes and
small businesses they carry over 600
sizes if you're one of those difficult
people they can even make custom filters
just for you plus they ship free within
24 hours and if that isn't enough all of
this is manufactured right here in the
United States so you have no excuse and
set up auto delivery so you don't have
to worry about checking those air
filters on a regular basis instead they
just arrive when they're supposed to
arrive plus you save 5% save money save
time breathe better with filter buy.com
I know I do this filter bu why.com
filter by com tell them been sent you
and we use it here daily way off since I
use it at my house as well
filter by comm filter Bui com+ just
wanted to make clear to you that our
next episode of the conversation is
coming up tomorrow Tuesday June 19 5:30
p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific in which
all of your questions will be answered
by me bench appear with our host Alicia
Krause our live Q&A is available on
YouTube and Facebook for everybody to
watch only subscribers get to ask
questions over at daily wire.com check
out our pin comments on this video for
more information so go check that out
right now alrighty so the big news of
the day is that apparently Donald Trump
hates children now if you're on the left
this comes as no surprise because you
always thought that Donald Trump hated
children right I mean that's not a giant
shock but the reality is that Donald
Trump supposedly is a guy who wants to
remove children from the arms of their
parents as those parents cross the
border illegally so you're coming across
the border to make a new life for
yourself and you brought your child and
you're picked up by ice and they cruelly
take
those children and they rip them away
from you they take the children they
just they rip them away from you
okay there is only one problem with all
of this okay there's only one problem
with all of this this is just not the
case okay the reason I say this is just
not the case I'm gonna go through the
actual applicable law here so you know
what it is that is going on okay the
reality is that the law requires that if
you cross the border illegally and we
arrest you for it that your children
cannot stay in custody with you hey
that's just the way it is okay the way
that it is according to the law okay and
that is a that is a 2008 ruling from the
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals according
to the law you are not allowed to take
the children and leave them with their
parents in custody is the Ninth Circuit
Court ruled that non detention of minors
applies to accompany two legal
immigrants the reason this happened is
there was an agreement it's called the
Flores agreement back from the 1990s in
which the federal government was sued
and they came into a federal settlement
and the federal settlement said that
when unaccompanied illegal children come
across the border they have to be
released remanded into the custody of
some sort of parental figure or guardian
in the United States and then the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals in 2016 ruled
that those children actually had to be
released whether or not they came with a
parent so you come across with mommy and
daddy we still cannot keep you in
custody for a long period of time we
still have to release you ASAP now the
problem with this is this has created a
spate of headlines that Donald Trump
because he is more strictly enforcing
border laws that because he is doing
that this means that you aren't that he
is somehow separating the children from
their parents again it is by operation
of law that the kids are removed from
their parents it is not Donald Trump
decided I want to remove children from
their parents and therefore I'm cruel
and nasty and that's what I want to do
that's not how any of this works rich
Lowry has a good column making all of
this clear
he points out in his column a National
Review today the Trump administration is
not changing the rules that pertain to
separating an adult from a child those
remain the same separation happens only
if officials find that the adult is
falsely claiming to be the child's
parent or as a threat to the child or is
put into criminal proceedings and it's
the last that is operative here the past
practice had been to give a free pass to
an adult who's part of a family unit the
new Trump policy is to prosecute all
adults the idea is to send a signal that
we are serious about our laws and to
create a deterrent against reentry
illegal entry is a misdemeanor
illegal reentry however is a felony when
a migrant is prosecuted for illegal
entry rights
rich Lowry here she has taken into
custody by the u.s. marshals
in no circumstance anywhere in the
United States do the marshals care for
the children of people they take into
custody the child is taken into the
custody of HHS that's Health and Human
Services who cares for them at temporary
shelters the criminal proceedings are
exceptionally short assuming there is no
aggravating factor such as a prior
illegal entity or another crime the
migrants generally plead guilty and they
are then sentenced to time served
typically on the same day although
practices vary along the border after
this their returns the custody of ice
for deportation if the adult then wants
to go home in keeping with the expedited
order of removal that is issued as a
matter of course it's relatively simple
the adult has reunited quickly with his
or her child and the family returned
home his unit in this scenario there's
only a brief separation when it does
become more of an issue is when parents
start claiming asylum if you claim
asylum adults are going to be detained
longer and the law is that you are not
allowed to hold children for longer than
20 days in custody and that's the Flores
consent decree now ruling by the Ninth
Circuit extended the 20-day limit to
children who come as part of family
Union so even if you would like to hold
the family unit together even if you
want the kid to stay with mommy and
daddy you cannot by operation of law you
are forbidden from doing so because the
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals wanted to
make it less appealing for the
government to keep families in custody
they wanted all of these families
released into the general population in
the United States rich Lowry writes the
clock ticking on the time the government
can hold the child will almost always
run out before an asylum claim is
settled the migrants is allowed ten days
to seek an attorney there may be
continuances or other complications this
creates the choice of either releasing
the adults and the children together
into the country pending the
adjudication of the asylum claim or
holding the children holding the adults
and releasing the children if the adult
has held HHS places that came with a
responsible party in the in the US
ideally a relative even if Flores didn't
exist the government would be very
constrained and how many family units it
can accommodate ice only has about 3,000
family spaces and shelters it is also
limited in its overall space at the
border which is overwhelmed by the
ongoing influx so family units can go
home quickly all they have to do is not
plead asylum and they can all go home
together also there's a better way to
claim asylum so the separation of
parents from children only happens if
you are arrested if you walk up to a
border station in the United States you
don't go between border stations you
just walk up to for example the
us-mexico border you know down near San
Diego if you just walk up to that border
and you say I need to claim asylum you
will not be
arrested you are only arrested if you
try to cross between the borders because
then the idea is probably you're lying
to get into the country otherwise you
should just walk up to Border Patrol not
along the border but in specific border
stations which everybody knows where
they are and then you claim asylum and
then you're not arrested at all then you
get to stay with your kids right every
indication is that the migrant flow to
the United States is discretionary it
nearly dried up at the beginning of the
Trump administration when migrants
believed they had no chance of getting
into the United States now it's going in
earnest again because the message got
out that despite the rhetoric the policy
at the border hasn't actually changed
even if a migrant does have credible
fear of persecution rights Lowry there
is a legitimate way to pursue that claim
it is not involved entering the United
States illegally first such people
should make their asylum claim in the
first country where they feel safe I for
example Mexico second if for some reason
they are threatened everywhere but the
United States they should show up at a
port of entry that's what it's called
the technical term a port of entry and
they make their claim there rather than
crossing the border illegally there's
significant moral cost to not enforcing
the border as well as rich Lowry points
out if you just start releasing people
in general into the middle of the
country lots more people are going to
start crossing into the country
illegally and it is well worth pointing
out that under the Obama administration
and under the Bush administration really
immigration surges were rooted in
government policy so July 7th 2014 this
is from the New York Times it was one of
the final pieces of legislation signed
into law by President George W Bush a
measure that passed without controversy
along with a pension bill and another
one calling for national parks to be
commemorated on quarters this is a piece
of legislation we're very proud to sign
a White House spokesman Tony Fratto told
reporters December 28th 2008 this
program has been very effective around
the world in trying to stop trafficking
in persons now the legislation this is
the New York Times right not Breitbart
not in a right-wing publication now the
legislation enacted quietly during the
transition to the Obama administration
is at the root of the potentially
calamitous flow of unaccompanied minors
to the nation's southern border
originally pushed by a bipartisan
coalition of lawmakers as well as by
evangelical groups to combat sex
trafficking the bill gave substantial
new protections to children entering the
country alone who are not from Mexico or
Canada by prohibiting them from being
quickly sent back to their country of
origin instead they have an opportunity
to appear in an immigration hearing and
consult with an advocate this of course
with Langston it puts strains on the
system lengthens the amount of time that
these kids are in the system in the
first place
so they're a bunch of lies that are
being told right now and we'll go
through a lot of the lies that are being
told by the media in just a second but
some of the lies being told her that
Trump is randomly deciding to separate
kids at the border he doesn't have to do
that he does have to do that by
operation of law the only thing the
Trump administration is doing
differently is they are treating
everyone who is crossing the border
illegally as an illegal immigrant for
prosecution for purposes of prosecution
and then because you're doing that the
kids can't stay in custody with the
parents longer than 20 days and that is
operation of law once again now the
media are going nuts over all of this
and they are they're making a huge fuss
out of all of this and they're showing
up at the border and they are showing up
at these at these particular at these
particular border stations where the
kids are being held the kids are being
held separately in what are cages
essentially now when they say cages it
makes it sound like the you know it's
like a chicken coop like it's tiny it
isn't but of course technically their
cage is because it's chain-link fence
separating people so though the
administration is tried to fight back
against the cages the cages descriptor
saying the kids are being treated pretty
well the kids are being treated by some
accounts well by some accounts not as
well apparently one of the regulations
on the books is that federal employees
are not allowed to touch the kids for a
fear of lawsuit so that means that some
of the illegal immigrant children are
changing the diapers and let other
illegal immigrant children they don't
even know the conditions are not good
all of this is underfunded Congress
could solve all of this by the way and
Congress could solve all of this today
all they have to do is pass a law that
says that if you come into the country
illegally with your parents your parents
and you get to stay together where you
get to stay in custody together right
that would be the way that you fix this
law and then it's the parents option
whether they want the kids released to
the custody of the HHS or released to
the custody of a family member already
in the United States but they get to
stay with the parents otherwise right
Congress can do that tomorrow and
Congress should do that today or
tomorrow
apparently I'm hearing from the
speaker's office from speaker Ryan's
office that's exactly what speaker Ryan
is going to pursue plus funding for
expanded facilities to ensure that
parents can stay together with their
kids when they come across the border so
all of this is in the process of getting
solved I do find it somewhat suspicious
that the media have decided to jump both
feet on the bandwagon as though this is
some sort of great Human Rights
catastrophe brought on by the Trump
administration when of course all of
this started under the Obama
administration or at least it was
happening under the Obama administration
Brandon Darby from Breitbart
he had a bunch of photos I remember when
I was working at Breitbart so he put out
all these photos right these are all
photos of a bunch of people including
children who are at these detention
facilities doesn't look that great right
man this is from 2014 you can see all
the photos is from 2014 and it's
children who are separated from males
who are separated from females these
facilities are overcrowded right all
this was happening in 2015 there's
nothing new happening here but the
implication is there's something new
happening here because it's Trump and
that of course is not true right that's
just not true we're gonna get to the
media coverage of this in just a second
talk about the administration's response
and really what the administration did
do wrong in just a second first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
wink so all of this makes you want to
drink doesn't it I mean politics it's
not the kind of thing that makes you
want to be sober but the reality is that
if you just want to kick back at night
and have yourself a nicer evening well
that's what wink is for well we've all
taken time to wring ourselves out from
holiday parties halfway through the year
and you deserve wink wink makes it easy
to discover great wine winks wines
expert select wines match to your taste
personalized for you shipped right to
your door starting at just $13 a bottle
there's nothing like coming home to a
box of delicious wink wine selected just
for you so here's the way it works you
go to the wink palate profile quiz and
you answer a bunch of simple questions
that nobody would ever ask CT to ask you
really like how do you like your coffee
or do you like blueberries and then wing
sentence wines curated directly to your
tastes the more wines you write the more
personalized your monthly selections so
it's like Netflix except for wine each
month there are new delicious wines
they're insanely popular some of water
Rose day is making the rounds right now
no membership fees you can skip any
month you can cancel anytime
shipping is covered if you don't like a
bottle they send you they replace it
with a bottle you will love no questions
asked discover great wine today go to
try wink comm slash pen that's t ry winc
comm / Ben for $20 off it's try wink
comm / Ben and get 20 bucks off your
first shipment again try blink comm /
Ben it's fantastic it makes a great gift
if you're late for Father's Day get your
dad a subscription to this it's really
fantastic
try wink command / Ben people around the
office have tried wink wine and those
are days when we don't get a lot of work
done so try wink calm / Ben and you get
to try it for 20 bucks off your first
shipments try wink calm / man all right
so the the Trump administration with all
this set that the Trump administration
is basically following the law and if
you don't like the law change the law
administration to do a couple of things
wrong here so the first thing they did
wrong is they sent out Stephen Miller
and John Kelly to say incredibly dumb
things so Stephen Miller who's sort of
the president's immigration guru I know
Stephens I know Stephen I think Stephens
a nice guy but Stephen made the big
boo-boo I'm going out in public and
saying that we want to use the
separation of children from parents as a
deterrent to prevent people from
crossing the border he should not be
using the suffering of children as a
deterrent to keep parents from crossing
the border that's not the way to do this
to turn to crossing the border is that
you get sent back it should not be then
you take kids away from their parents
this causes psychological harm and
psychological damage it shouldn't be a
situation as we've heard from some of
these reports where the parents aren't
even told that they're being separated
from the kids the kids are sort of taken
away and then two hours later the
parents are so yeah by the way you're
not gonna be able to see your kid again
right that kind of stuff is a problem
and that kind of stuff is frightening it
should not be happening in the United
States to say that you're using that as
a deterrent effect that's a serious
problem and that should not be done
that's stupid Jeff Sessions also came
out and he quoted the Bible he said
listen the Bible says that you should
abide by the law I would cite you to the
Apostle Paul and his clear and wise
command in Romans 13 - oh babe laws of
the government because God is obtained
ok so again and I know senator sessions
or you know attorney general sessions
and I think on some of his immigration
policy he's been exactly right you
probably shouldn't be grinning so
broadly when you talk about separating
families from their children it's just
not smart if you for folks you can't see
the video you know he's he's standing
there and he's green pretty broadly he
quotes the Apostle Paul again you don't
have to do that just say abide by the
laws of this country this is a very
serious topic obviously well the
homeland security secretary secretary
Brigitte Nielsen our sorry Christian
Nielsen she has come forward and she
says that the the reporters and and by
members of Congress the reporting is not
true on this and she's correct she says
this misreporting by members press and
advocacy groups must stop and is
irresponsible and unproductive as I have
said many times before if you are
seeking asylum from your family there's
no reason to break the law and illegally
cross between ports of entry this is
exactly right right now the policy is if
you cross between ports of entry we will
arrest you and will prosecute you but if
you show up at one of the border ports
of entry then you'll be treated as an
asylum seeker you won't be separated
from your kids and she continues she
says you're not breaking the law by
seeking asylum in a port of entry and
she continues as well and she says for
those seeking asylum at ports of entry
we have continued the policy from
previous administrations and will only
separate if the child is in danger
there's no custodial relationship
between family members or if the adult
has broken a law and she finishes up for
those she says DHS takes very seriously
its duty to protect minors in our
temporary custody from gangs traffickers
criminals and abuse and then she
finishes by saying we do not have a
policy of separating families at the
border period everything she says there
is factually true now the media are
lying about this and in just a second
I'm gonna show you how the media are
lying about all of this and turning it
into a major issue when in fact this is
an easily solvable issue if we could
just get past all the politics so we
begin with Chuck Todd so Chuck Todd has
on Kellyanne Conway and NBC News on
Sunday and he says that the goal of the
Trump administration is to hold children
to hold hold children hostage to get
Democrats to pass some law that
obviously is not the goal here the
operation of law the operation of law
it's not up to trump the operation of
law says that if you arrest a parent
illegally crossing the border the kid
cannot be held in custody for longer
than 20 days that is the law Trump did
not make up the law Trump cannot violate
that law unless he just decides to
release illegal immigrant parents who
are crossing between border ports of
entry illegally yeah all the lies that
are being told today are really
astonishing and Chuck Todd for words
that game here and this is gonna sound
harsh but it sounds like you're holding
these kids hostage to get the Democrats
to the table to pass some law you just
laid out a very compassionate case for
why I understand you just let a very
competitive with a lot of compassion and
a lot of empathy in there but it's not
very empathetic than the most traumatic
thing to do to a kid separate them from
their parents okay so what's your
solution Chuck so what's your solution
Chuck right this is the part that's that
makes me crazy the solution that is
being proposed by people on the Left
said that Trump should just release
people into the interior of the United
States that is the solution that they
are proposing right now that is not a
solution there are laws on the books you
do not gets crossed into the country
illegally again we have provisions that
say if you come to a port of entry in
the United States then we will treat you
like a normal asylum seeker if however
you are sneaking through the brush near
Sonoma and you just decide to to cross
the border illegally not near a port of
entry and we catch you we're not going
to treat you as though you were an
asylum seeker because if your Asylum
seeker you were to go onto a port of
entry
right but the media are just lying flat
out about this I will say I thought that
the most hilarious things after Jeff
Sessions quoted the Bible to say that
people should abide by the law MSNBC
decided to ask what would Jesus do so
apparently Trump has now won the war on
Christmas
Trump has officially won the war on
Christmas because he's got the anchors
at MSNBC actually reading the Bible I do
enjoy when folks on the Left start
reading the Bible and they skip over all
the parts about you know like abortion
and same-sex marriage and adultery and
they skip over all of those parts and
they go straight to the most vague
portions that support their position so
here's Ali Velshi on MSNBC who I guess
went to some sort of seminary and he did
a full segment on MSNBC called what
would Jesus do about illegal immigration
but jesus said suffer little children
and forbid them not to come unto me for
of such is the kingdom of heaven
what is that's the only little grain in
Matthew chapter 25 again this time verse
40 and the King shall answer and say
unto them verily I say unto you in Doha
CNN MSNBC they have done it unto one of
the least of my brethren ye have done it
unto me
that's just a small sampling of what's
in the Bible well hallelujah MSNBC
calling out the priests and the pastor's
to talk about everything that's going on
on the border again you're not gonna see
them do this with regard to Planned
Parenthood that was the most ironic
tweeting all this Planned Parenthood
tweeted this out so here's a Planned
Parenthood tweeted they tweeted out in
our hearts and minds today all of the
fathers and parents have been separated
from their children at borders keep
families together hashtag Father's Day
and then it says you deserve to be
together regardless of immigration
status keeping families together is
reproductive justice you kill babies
okay that's what Planned Parenthood does
for a living three hundred thousand
unborn children a year and whatever you
may say about separating families from
children at the border and again I think
there's an easy congressional fix to all
of this that speaker Ryan's offices told
me they're already pursuing today you
know even if you believe that that's
something that ought to be fixed what
Planned Parenthood's does to kids a lot
worse than separating them at the border
for a week and a half okay they kill
them so I do love how the left suddenly
is interested in God in the Bible when
it comes to illegal immigration by the
way I just want to note this you know
and someone who's fond of the Old
Testament right I wear the funny hat on
my head
I'm fond of the Old Testament and I like
it in the original Hebrew you know the
hardcore way and whenever it talks about
treating strangers in your land with
certain respect the precondition in all
of Jewish law for all the Jewish
histories that people have to accept the
law of land if you violate the law of
land you're not treated like a stranger
in the land like a garret aschoff right
you instead are treated like somebody
who is violating the laughlin were
treated like a criminal
so to misquote the Bible purposefully is
really ridiculous
now the worst of all is Kathy Griffin of
course because Kathy Griffin only makes
a headline when she says something
absolutely awful so she decided that she
would go off on on Melania she said f
you Melania you know damn well your
husband can end this immediately
feckless complicit piece of bleep I do
love that so many folks on the left are
so angry all the women in the Trump
administration they're feckless and
complicit but so funny all those people
wouldn't say that Hillary Clinton was
feckless and complicit when it came to
her husband's exploitation of women but
it's a different thing when you're
talking immigration policy and Melania
Trump like Melania is just going to
stroll on into the Oval and suddenly
trump's gonna shift his immigration
policy cuz Melania said something now
really the routine that is making the
most that is making the most headlines
today is Laura Bush has an op-ed today
that we need to go through in just a
second plus you have a bunch of preening
Democratic lawmakers I want to talk
about first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at stamps calm so right
now you can get practically everything
on demand right I get everything on
demand I get my entertainment on demand
I get products on demand so why you're
still taking trips to the post office to
mail letters and packages doesn't matter
how much you love the post office it's
pretty great but the reality is you can
save a lot of time money simply by
staying in your office and going over to
stamps calm you can access all the
amazing services of the post office
right from your desk 24/7 when it is
convenient for you you can buy a print
official US postage for any letter any
package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier picks it up you
just click print mail and you're done
and then go over to stamps comm you get
a special deal right now when you use
promo code Shapiro
it includes fifty five bucks of free
postage a digital scale and four week
free trial which is pretty amazing so go
check it out right now when you go to
stamps calm before you do anything else
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage type in Shapiro that
stamps comm and enter promo code Shapiro
again it includes up to $50 $5 free
postage ooh digital scale and a four
week trial see whether you like it we
use stamps calm here at the Daily wire
offices to see this a lot of time I
don't have to have our employees run
over to the post office
it saves me a lot of time at home again
just prints it right
out on the envelope the postage they
give you a postage meter as well a
digital scale rather and that allows you
to know what kind of postage you need
for all this stuff it's just great go to
stamps comm check it out and use promo
code Shapiro to let them know we sent
you and so you got the special deal
all right so Laura Bush has now sounds
it off now I do find this weird okay I
really like Laura Bush I have a lot of
respect for Laura Bush I think choose a
very good first lady but I don't know
why it was that Laura Bush was silent
about so much of policy under the Obama
administration and now she is speaking
out about the Trump administration I
suppose the idea here is that
Republicans are supposed to police their
own so when something really bad happens
Republicans are supposed to speak up
that's fine with me but I think that
this particular piece is not supremely
accurate and not only do I think that
it's not supremely accurate I think that
it actually forward some falsehoods so
here's what Laura Bush has to station is
on Sunday a day we as a nation set aside
to honor fathers and the bonds of family
I was among the millions of Americans
who watched images of children who have
been torn from their parents in the six
weeks between April 19th and May 31st
the Department of Homeland Security has
sent nearly 2,000 children to mass
detention centers or foster care more
than 100 of these children are younger
than four years old the reason for these
separations is a zero-tolerance policy
for their parents who are accused of
illegally crossing our borders well
they're not accused they illegally
crossed our borders and I live in a
border state
I appreciate the need to enforce and
protect our international boundaries but
the zero tolerance policy is cruel it is
immoral and it breaks my heart so again
here's the problem I understand empathy
empathy makes for bad politics it does
ok sympathy makes for good politics
empathy makes for bad politics sympathy
is I feel bad for you empathy is I feel
you meaning I am putting myself in your
shoes
well how about putting yourself in the
shoes of the immigration agent who has
to decide whether to release an unvetted
illegal immigrant family into the
country ok there are stories by the way
of gangs who have been smuggling
children across the border specifically
for this purpose because they know that
if they have a kid with them they're
more likely to be released into sort of
general sight now it's rarity but it is
happening and we have to be vetting who
comes into the country in the first
place is the policy supposed to be that
you show up with a six-month-old then we
just release you into the country
because right now that's the law right
now you have two choices I can either
arrest the parent and separate out the
kid or I can release them into the
country if the idea is you come in with
a kid under 4 you get released how many
people do you think are gonna rush that
border a lot a lot of people does not
say you should create a policy to deter
aggression by separating the kids
instead you should change the power
see so the kids get to stay with the
parents in some sort of custody that'd
be the way to do this but if the
alternative is released a bunch of kids
in the middle of the country with their
parents I just don't see that here's
what Laura Bush read she's our
government should not be in the business
of warehousing children in converted box
stores or making plans to place them in
tent cities in the desert outside El
Paso these images are eerily reminiscent
of the Japanese internment camps of
World War two
now considered to have been one of the
most shameful episodes in American
history we also know this treatment
inflicts trauma in turn Japanese have
been 2 times as likely to suffer
cardiovascular disease or die
prematurely than those who are not
interred this is not Japanese American
internment okay that was taking American
citizens and forcibly relocating them to
camps when they were integrated into
American society already they had rights
under the US Constitution the same is
not true of people illegally crossing
the border and again it was the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals the most left
Court in America that made this policy
it was not Trump I don't like the
inaccuracy here he can make a case for
legislation that fixes all of this
without being inaccurate about your
reporting Laura Bush continues Americans
pride ourselves on being a moral nation
on being the nation that sends
humanitarian relief to places devastated
by natural disasters or famine or war we
pride ourselves on believing that people
should be seen for the content of their
character not the color of their skin we
pride ourselves on acceptance if we are
truly that country then it is our
obligation to reunite these detained
children with their parents and to stop
separating parents and children in the
first place people on all sides agree
our immigration system isn't working but
the injustice of zero tolerance is not
the answer I moved away from Washington
almost a decade ago but I know there are
good people at all levels of government
who can do better to fix all of this
says in 2018
can we not find an it and can we not as
a nation find a kinder more
compassionate and more moral answer to
this current crisis I for one believe we
can yes of course we can but this starts
by not being inaccurate about the state
of law it starts by not being accurate
about the state law it also starts by
not being at inaccurate about illegal
immigration and the cost of illegal
immigration now there's been a lot of
talk about illegal immigration
increasing crime rates the data are
mixed on all of that there's been a lot
of talk about illegal immigration and
its effects on the economy the evidence
suggests that the illegal immigrants are
more of a drain on the economy that
helps the economy since they don't pay
taxes they paste you know state sales
tax but that's about it but it is
certainly true that every crime that is
committed by an illegal immigrant inside
the United States is a crime that didn't
need to happen for example over the
weekend all
he said five undocumented immigrants are
dead following a chase involving Border
Patrol agents on Sunday afternoon
Dimmick County Sheriff Marion Boyd said
the crash happened off highway 85 in big
wells in about noon Boyd said agents
were chasing the SUV but it lost control
it overturned the vehicle was traveling
at more than a hundred miles per hour
when it crashed 14 people were inside
including the driver and passenger 12
immigrants were ejected four died at the
scene when the car crashed and rolled
over according to Boyd a fifth person
later died at the hospital
a total of nine people were transported
to the hospital including five who went
to San Antonio Military Medical Center
the restaurants and local hospitals the
driver is a United States citizen who
was among those transported a Border
Patrol agent observed three vehicles
traveling one behind the other on FM in
2664 and suspected a smuggling attempt
was happening the agency said in a
statement the agent was able to stop one
of the vehicles and called out a
description of the other two a second
Border Patrol agent was able to pull
over the second vehicle the third
refused to stop the agents he said
multiple arrests were made in both
vehicles the passenger also believed to
be a US citizen is currently in custody
Boyd says they need a wall built in this
area because this is a real problem in
the area okay so well there's a lot of
talk about weakening immigration law you
know we ought to remember that a country
worth its salt does have borders now
lawmakers are making hay while the Sun
shines here smart politicians Michael
Hayden General Michael Hayden who is a
member of the Obama administration I
believe I would have to actually look up
his credentials but Michael Hayden
tweeted this out like Laura Bush you
know trying to compare all of this to
internment camps
Michael Hayden then tweeted out a
picture of the railway station at
Auschwitz
Riley cash was Birkenau any tweet our
other governments have separated mothers
and children this is so insulting and so
insanely stupid I can't even tell you it
is bad enough to compare this to
japanese-american internment camps
because it is not similar okay it isn't
but to compare it to the Nazis is just
insane he's a retired US Air Force
four-star general he's former Director
of National Security Agency and former
director of the CIA is Michael Hayden
the the fact that he thinks this just
demonstrates the lack of knowledge and
all levels of the American government
there was separation of children from
parents at Auschwitz and then both were
gassed and then they gassed every child
to death and they gassed most of the
mothers to death as well that is not the
same thing as we're going to put you in
protective custody while we take care of
your parents asylum claim
not quite the same thing at all but it's
just it's just ridiculous again all this
media coverage is ridiculous all of it
is unfair and all of it is designed to
elicit an emotional response when an
emotional response may be merited right
you can you can see a reason for being
emotional about all this stuff what you
can't see is lying about all of this and
this is indeed lies I mean these are
lies okay so you're gonna have to go
over to Daley we're now calm for the
rest of the show live even for $9.99 a
month to get the rest of this show there
are some animal Clavin show there are
some Michael Moses show Plus as I said
earlier on the show we have an episode
of the conversation coming up tomorrow
then that episode of the conversation
will include me taking your questions
when you are subscriber you get your
questions asked when you aren't you
don't you just sit there in chastened
silence as they answer the questions of
others if you get the annual
subscription you get this the very
greatest in leftist cheers ha trickled
tumblers it is just fantastic it is
magnificent when I go to public events I
see people bring them with them they
cherish them they treasure them they put
them in glass cases that they are not
harmed that's how great these are that's
how much people love the tumblers you
get that for $99 a year cheaper than the
monthly subscriptions to go check that
out right now also go check out our
YouTube and in our in our iTunes page
please subscribe please leave us a
review we always appreciate with another
Sunday special they came out yesterday
with Michael Shermer you're really going
to enjoy when you subscribe you get that
as well another something special next
week
I'm trying number who we have next week
it's will get it to you tomorrow yeah
Jason Whitlock that's exactly right I
didn't remember how we were scheduling
so Jason Whitlock
is is next week the the former Kansas
City Star columnist and sports columnist
will talk sports and everything else so
check that out as well we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so among all of these stupid responses
to this immigration debacle is Bill
Clinton so Bill Clinton responded to all
of us because we obviously mean his take
on the immigration situation he tweeted
out on this Father's Day I'm thinking of
the thousands of children separated from
their parents at the border honestly I
thought on Father's Day he might be
thinking of all the children he's never
met that he has you know this Father's
Day I'm thinking of thousands of
children separated from their parents
bore these children should not be a
negotiating to and reuniting them with
their families would reaffirm America's
belief in and support for all parents
who love their children ok well I seem
to remember back to the 90s you know
like flashback back to the 90s remember
this picture remember this one yeah yeah
that was when they took Elian Gonzales
from his family at gunpoint and then
sends him back to Cuba right because we
had to have good relations with Cuba is
very important so we actually sent a
SWAT team in for a move Elian Gonzalez
from the United States but apparently on
Father's Day this is what Bill Clinton
doesn't remember I bill clinton amidst
his hookers and blow he's sitting around
thinking about all of the children
separate from their parents at the
border all of this is just overwrought
and has nothing to do with the actual
law again there will be a law passed
this week to fix this process as well
there should have been before now I'm
glad there's focus on it because I think
the process ought to be fix but there's
no reason to lie about it and you see
all these lawmakers who are lying about
it here in lawmakers holding a press
conference after touring in the
immigration facility
there's representative Sheila
jackson-lee one of the greater
demagogues in the country Democrat from
Texas and here she is making making the
fuss let me just quickly say that when
you have a mother tell you directly that
she's in fear that she will never see
her child again when the United Nations
Human Rights Commission indicates to the
Trump administration you're violating
Human Rights then you know that what we
are saying today is President Trump
cease and desist because you are moving
the arc of Justice to the heat of
despair and the trash heap of injustice
so after the parents are in handcuffs
their kids are taken away to parts
unknown that is appalling
it is an American as Peter Walter
Democrat from Vermont
heap of despair and trash heap of
history and arcs of justice and oh my
goodness okay if you're a parent and you
feel like you're never gonna get your
kid back that's horrifying obviously
which is why we should correct the
situation it is also
that every child has been returned to
their parent has it been a case where a
kid has been permanently removed from
their parent have we heard of any of
those cases no because this is all
exaggeration okay now again the policy
is not good but this policy was not
implemented by the Trump administration
all they're doing is enforcing the
immigration law that's it that's the
whole thing okay but it's just it's it's
so irritating to watch people fib and
lie about the situation and this stuff
is it's just it's fibs and it's lies and
it's inappropriate to fibbin lie about
politics even if you think that it's
gonna be helpful these are the same
people who say the Trump lies routinely
well the media are lying about the
situation and it's really really
unpleasant okay now speaking of
unpleasant Peter struck you'll recall
last week we talked at length about the
Department of Justice Inspector General
report about the FBI's actions in the
Hillary Clinton email case and that IG
report was pretty damning the person at
the center of the IG report was Peter
struck Peter struck was an FBI agent who
was one of the head agents in charge of
both the Russia investigation as well as
the Hillary Clinton email investigation
and you'll recall that there was a text
that he sent to his lover he's a
delightful fellow who's married having
an affair with a woman who's also
married so just delightful people all
the way around and she texted that Trump
wouldn't be President she hopes
basically and he said we'll stop it
write those direct quote we'll stop it
which is just fantastic
so now struck says that he will testify
before the House Judiciary Committee
without a subpoena according to his
lawyer 8:00 in Berlin he wrote the House
Judiciary Committee chairman Bob
Goodlatte a letter obtained by law and
crime quote I have read press reports
that you're initiating the process to
issue a subpoena to Special Agent struck
to testify before your committee well
you are of course free to continue
pursuing this process it is wholly
unnecessary specialist special agent
struck who's been fully cooperative with
the DOJ Office of Inspector General
intends to voluntarily appear and
testify before your committee and any
other congressional committee that
invites him so the reason that he's so
eager to get in front of the committee
obviously is because he can fib about
all of this he can just say when I said
we'll stop it I mean all of the
anti-trump voters right that's really
what I meant or when I said that I don't
want Trump to be President you know I
was gonna use my official auspices to do
all of this or when I decided that I was
going to delay the decision-making about
Hillary Clinton's email investigation to
pursue the Russian investigation which
is what happened between late September
and late October and when I made that
decision that wasn't politically
motivated after all if I were
politically motivated I would released
all this stuff to the press
already said all this stuff to the goj
and the DOJ itself found some of this
stuff not incredible at the DOJ itself
said that it had problems with struct
story that had thought that it cast
really bad light on the FBI's actions in
the Hillary Clinton email case on
Thursday the DOJ z' office of the
Inspector General blasted struck for his
behavior amid the probes into Russia
collusion and Hillary Clinton's emails
to say they were ambivalent doesn't
quite capture their tone on the one hand
investigators said they found no
evidence tying investigative decisions
to anti-trump messages involving struck
according to law and crime comm on the
other hand quote when one senior FBI
official struck will help lead the
Russia investigation at the time conveys
in a text message to another senior FBI
official page that quote will stop
candidate Trump from being elected after
other extensive text messages between
the two disparaging candidate Trump it
is not only indicative of a bias state
of mind but even more seriously implies
a willingness to take official action to
impact the president the presidential
candidates electoral prospects this is
antithetical to the core values of the
FBI and the DOJ moreover as we described
in Chapter nine in assessing strux
decision to prioritize the Russia
investigation over following on the
Hillary related investigative lead
discovered on the Weiner laptop in
October 2016 these text messages led us
to conclude we did not have confidence
that structs decision was free from bias
so how's the lawyer fighting back he
says well special agent struck did not
back burner inspection of the Weiner
laptop in fall of 2016
second while special agent struck openly
admitted he believed the Russian
investigation was far more important to
American national security than the
Clinton email investigation this
conclusion is evidence of special agents
trucks lucidity not as bias I'm and so I
guess struck is eager to testify because
he's eager to grandstand about all of
the Russian collusion that's supposedly
going on now again there's been no
actual evidence presented as of yet of
anything beyond attempted collusion now
attempted collusion ain't great but it
ain't the same as actual collusion
struck wants to get in front of Congress
who wants to get in front of those
cameras it needs to happen right and and
here's the reality no matter what he
says the left will claim that struck was
acting in the best interests of the
country and the right will suggest I
think rightly so that bias was taking
place with regard to the Russia
investigation and the Hillary
investigation bottom line is that struck
is still working at the FBI how he has
not been fired is absolutely beyond me
it's absolutely beyond me no other area
of American government would you be
allowed to get away with this if you
were a local police officer and there
were a shooting and they found
in your messages text messages about the
person that you shot then about how you
were eager to watch that person die
right presumably you'd be prosecuted hey
Peter struck basically did that with
regard to the Trump investigation and
we're all supposed to pretend that it
didn't happen yeah that's ridiculous
okay
and now meanwhile speaking of ridiculous
you know there's a lot of talk on
college campuses these days about
structural bias about racism
institutional racism well now it turns
out that Harvard University is
institutionally racist so a group that
is suing Harvard University is demanding
that a publicly released admissions data
on hundreds of thousands of applicants
saying the records show a pattern of
discrimination against asian-americans
going back decades the group was able to
view the documents through its lawsuit
which was filed in 2014 and challenged
ins Harvard's admissions policies
basically what they found is that
Harvard kept saying over and over and
over that all Asian applicants were not
good leaders basically they said that
they were not good leaders or they had
personal flaws and that's why they
couldn't be admitted despite higher test
scores and what you see is a bevy so the
Caltech it's not fascinating chart of
the weekend Caltech admits people simply
on the basis of scores and on the basis
of grades and what you saw is that the
number of asian-americans at Caltech has
been increasing dramatically over the
past twenty years it started off at like
at you know a certain level and then it
rose dramatically to the point where it
is now and it looks like a straight line
up basically it's an arithmetic aliy
increasing line well if you look at the
the levels at Harvard what you see is a
boost in the eighties of asian-american
people attending Harvard and then it
flattens out and the state of flat ever
since the 90s and the same is held true
at Yale and the same until true at NYU
and the same is held true at most major
college universities which suggests that
there is racism going on and so the
racism is coming from the left in the
form of admissions bias to prevent
asian-americans from getting into
schools you want to talk about
institutional racism we should be
talking about institutional racism on
the part of these universities now in
other news on Father's Day well it's a
good time to celebrate fathers the good
news is that the left has decided that
fathers are useless Noah Berle at ski is
a columnist for NBC News and he writes
for there think page this Father's Day
men are experiencing a crisis of
masculinity the solution more feminism
yeah that's probably it
yeah that'll probably fix it tell your
boy that he that he oughta wear a tutu
that's
gonna fix it or tell your boy don't rape
that's probably gonna fix this thing
it's not that you need men modelling
better behavior what you really need is
men preaching the messages and Gloria
Steinem that's definitely gonna solve
things here's what the piece says we are
experiencing a crisis of masculinity
that's the claim of Canadian
psychologist and self-help author Jordan
Peterson Pearson argues that feminism
and policies like no-fault divorce have
destabilized traditional family and
social structures has a fix for this
Peterson recommends a variety of things
including enforced monogamy a solution
that implies men are oppressed due to
lack of context consensual sex okay
first of all that is a lie that we've
talked about on the show before turn
Peterson when he says enforced monogamy
he does not mean government enforcement
agha me he means a societal standard
that promotes monogamy which I thought
feminists would be for in many cases so
that men wouldn't be scumbags cheating
on them on a routine basis
Peterson's claims have been broadly
criticized but he does have his
defenders as well he's often argued that
the crisis of masculinity has been
caused by feminism which has led to
evolving norms generating confusion and
mixed signals in the words of Cathy
young writing in the LA Times feminism
has sent men adrift they're no longer
sure how to be men and as a result they
are struggling economically and
psychologically well that is kind of
true but here's what Norbert Lansky says
he says men experience violence and
oppression because norms are not
changing and it is in general powerful
men who saw who enforce these unhelpful
and sometimes dangerous masculine
expectations not tyrannous feminist
women as in one example consider male
suicide rates men are victims of
three-quarters of suicides in the United
States this isn't because feminists have
successfully carried out a campaign to
keep men from having sex rather male
suicide rates are tragically high
because of traditional stereotypical
standards of manliness well that's
idiotic
okay if that were really the case if you
really believe that as traditional
standards of stereotypical masculinity
then why exactly has male suicide
increased right if the standards were
the same 50 years ago as they are today
you would expect the suicide rate to be
the same 50 years ago as it was today it
isn't
but Norbert alaskey has an idiotic point
to make and here's the City otic point
our culture tells men they are supposed
to be emotionally and physically strong
in self-contained
it is not surprising therefore the men
are less likely to seek medical help for
mental health problems oh that's it
that's it it's the men won't go to the
doctor that's why they're dying in
higher numbers sure they didn't go to
the doctor fifty years ago but it's that
they won't go to the doctor now
encouraging boys not to cry as dangerous
encouraging boys to love guns is even
more so okay again loving guns has been
part of male culture for as long as guns
have been around
and encouraging boys not to cry okay I
don't think anybody should cry unless it
is warranted boys or girls and then they
didn't he talks about had gender
expectations and stereotypical views of
men mass incarceration
disproportionately affects black people
and people of color but it also and
relatedly affects men well no it turns
out that men have always gone to prison
at higher rates because men are more
aggressive biologically so in order to
get to this idiotic point basically no
Prelutsky has to suggest that the only
thing that has changed is the men who
become Moore's which is stupid and
untrue and the other thing that has
changed that societal standards have
changed and this is making men more
unhappy in certain ways and maybe we
should take a look at the societal
standards and determine whether they are
useful or not and whether they are
counterproductive or not okay time for
some stuff I like and then some stuff I
hate and then we'll do a Federalist
paper so the thing I like today there's
a I get a lot of questions about what
kind of Jewish literature is worth
reading there's an excellent book I
finished over the weekend by Michael
Goodman this this came out in Hebrew in
Israel has been translated now it's
called Maimonides and the book that
changed Judaism secrets of the guides
for the guide for the perplexed it
really is a sophisticated take on guide
for the perplexed which was a very
difficult book to read almost you know
it's rishta chilean philosophy and
theology when you've read some Plato
it's it's a very complex book Leo
Strauss is one of the great philosophers
of the twentieth century has about 500
pages of essays on the guide for the
perplexed
well Michael Goodman breaks it down in
very user-friendly fashion books um
about two hundred forty forty pages
something like that really worth a read
Michael Goodman's Maimonides in the book
that changed the Judaism so if you're
interested in sort of a good take on
what Judaism constitutes this is a
pretty good primer on some basic
philosophy in Judaism it'sit's
definitely worth the read okay other
things that are like so this was
hilarious
so Jimmy Kimmel was criticizing Ted Cruz
and Ted Cruz challenged Jimmy Kimmel to
a game of basketball and Jimmy Kimmel
took him up on it now I'm old enough to
remember because I'm from Los Angeles
when Jimmy Kimmel was the sports guy on
Kevin and bean on K Rock 106.7 out here
he was the sport that was literally how
he started his career he started his
career by giving the sports updates in
the morning on K Rock now suffice it to
say that I did not listen to K rock on
my own I was in a carpool and I used to
sit in the middle of the backseat in
carpool because I was the smallest kid
and I did not get to choose what was on
the radio but that man I heard a lot of
Jimmy Kimmel in his younger days and
doing the sports updates the sports guy
played Ted Cruz and Ted Cruz beat him
Ted Cruz beat Jimmy Kimmel in basketball
which is just as cynical he beat him
apparently 11:00 to 9:00 and Ted Cruz
had a good sense of humor about the
whole thing he went out took a picture
with Grayson Allen because they're
look-alikes Grayson Allen the Duke star
and Ted Cruz and he beat him 11 and 9 it
raised a bunch of money for charity and
this leads me to think that we should
have more charity basketball games
between celebrities because it's
something like 5,000 people showed up
which is more than a typical WNBA game
so why not Ted Cruz versus Jimmy Kimmel
I'd be more interested in watching that
than the WNBA I mean I'm sure the level
of the skill is higher in the WNBA but
still Jimmy Kimmel and it's a disgrace
to the game of basketball I'm sure but
it was pretty funny I mean if you look
at the footage so good for Ted Cruz
that's got to be just a blot on Jimmy
Kimmel's record he's just got to go home
and cry about that every night and he
got beat by Ted Cruz in basketball hi
larrya's okay time for a thing that I
hate
all right so Van Jones right head on Kim
Kardashian Kim Kardashian of course is
one of the great moral voices of our
time she just as we know freed Alice
Johnson from prison the 63 year old drug
dealer who dealt in 3,000 kilograms of
cocaine something like that so that's
that's very exciting so she got one
person free now she's apparently looking
for other people on death row that she
can go to president Trump with and try
to get him to pardon says very exciting
man Jones sat down with Kim Kardashian
and he asked her if she wanted to run
for public office oh would you ever run
for office oh I don't I don't think
that's even on my mind
trump's president it could happen I know
that's why Kanye loves him it's the idea
that anything can happen so good
anything happen with that I guess never
say never but that's not gonna be like a
Kim's run-in yeah Never Say Never for
Kim Kardashian that's just what we need
great okay you made a celebrity culture
live in that celebrity culture it's
garbage it's garbage just cuz people are
famous doesn't mean that they're smart
or know what they're doing on politics
or know that I know I know we're all
supposed to pretend that it's wonderful
because Kim Kardashian's talking with
Trump and now we're all supposed to
pretend this is like a great thing yay
so exciting oh okay I am NOT excited -
Kim Kardashian is talking with trunks I
don't think she knows things I think she
knows things about certain things I
don't think that the criminal justice
system is one of those things if
wants to talk with an expert referred by
Kim Kardashian that's one thing but if
Kim Kardashian is now going to be a
politician I hate that our pilot that
our politics has now suggested that
study reading books knowing things these
are negatives it makes you Heidi toidy
to know stuff what what utter what utter
nonsense and stupidity
okay one more thing that I hate so
there's an article at a site called the
cut about by a about a woman who had her
boyfriend move in with her and her
husband and they had a kid so well done
on screwing up your kid and here's what
the piece says by Arielle Greenberg has
told to Kim Brooks Rob and I were
together for 12 years before we decided
to open our marriage it happened not
long that after not that long after we
had our last child for most of our
relationship I've been very focused on
my career and then motherhood without
much time to think about my sex life
once we were done having kids my sex
drive came roaring back we loved each
other very much but we never been a
perfect match in terms of sexual
compatibility I told him I didn't think
our marriage was big enough for my new
sexual curiosity I wanted to explore Rob
was very receptive but we wanted to take
things slowly okay so note two ladies
who say they want an open marriage
the reason your husband is very
receptive to open marriage is because
men are naturally polygamous and wants
to go screw as many women as possible so
no wonder your husband wanted in are you
sure like shocker okay and then first of
all I don't believe I'm gonna say this I
don't believe that a lot that the issue
of sexual compatibility is a real issue
I think it's an issue a personal
compatibility treated extended into the
realm of sex that's what I think about
sexual compatibility I think that if
you're a giving person in the bedroom
you're likely to have a very good sex
life I think that if you're an a-hole in
real life you are likely to be an a-hole
in the bedroom I think that's just the
way that it works I think that if two
people love each other and they give to
each other they will have a very good
sex life if not they'll have a garbage
sex life this issue of oh you know we
love each other and really getting all
great in every other aspect of life but
just in the bedroom or really bad
together I think you're doing something
wrong I think you're doing something
wrong and I blame you okay I don't blame
it on oh you have exquisite sexual taste
and now I need to go out and explore the
world and do the Cirque de Soleil tour
of sex I just don't buy it I think it's
because you're I think you're not
working hard enough on your relationship
now that's it sometimes there are
physical actual problems sound I'm
talking about I'm not talking about you
have some sort of physical defect I'm
not talking about you experience pain or
something like that I'm talking about
well you know you can have a perfectly
comfortable sex but you're just not that
into each other sexually and all this
will work on it stop being a jerk okay
here's it so
this article continues and then
apparently we were very open about what
we were doing with everyone including
our kids who are four and eight at the
time because you will burn in hell okay
then we sat down with them and explained
that some people think when you're
married to someone you can only love
that one person but that we didn't
believe that we thought you could love
more than one person at the same time
our oldest child thought about it and
said for a moment then said well right I
love you and I also love data and I said
right and that was the end of the
conversation that's not the same thing
that is not the same thing
I'm sorry having sex with multiple
people is not the same thing as I love
my wife and I love my child unless
you're really perverse okay like that's
that's not the way that works right
there I say children are naturally very
tolerant about these things we teach
them our intolerance right cuz children
are stupid right cuz children are
dummies okay I've got two kids under
five they're wonderful they're very
smart for their age they're dummies
okay that's because they're they're kids
like you're supposed to inculcate good
values okay anyway both of us started
dating says this article Rob began
dating a woman pretty seriously and I
was seeing my quiet first met in my
twenties ahaha this is what was really
going on she hooked up on Facebook with
an old boyfriend right we'd had a
passion of a brief relationship by
living on opposite coasts we had since
fallen out of touch now he was living
five hours away and women began a
long-distance relationship where I'd see
him every month or two for a couple of
days after about two years of
long-distance dating and getting to know
our whole family Mike decided to move to
our town to be close to us he was
divorced and had no kids in a job he
could do from anywhere when he first
moved here ents in an apartment flew by
a few blocks away the idea was he lived
there for a year or more and we'd see
how it went but it became immediately
apparent that it didn't just make sense
because he and I wanted to spend every
night together and he was eating all
those meals with us so it turns out that
she wasn't like just not happy with her
husband she won't have sex with him at
all she wouldn't have had sex with his
other dude but she wanted to have her
cake and eat it too
Robin Mike got along well from the start
not like best friends
but they genuinely enjoyed each other's
company if I wasn't home they'd watch
basketball and make dinner together
because your husband is a doof they
wouldn't turn to each other they
wouldn't turn to each other if they were
in crisis for that they turned to me but
they got along well of all the questions
people ask me about non-monogamy the one
I get most is probably at the living
arrangement people want to know why Mike
got to live with us well none of the
people Robin dated got to this seems
like such a silly way to look at it the
reasons you do or don't choose deliver
the partner are complicated it's not
that Mike got to live with us instead it
made sense for him to move in he was
getting a divorce
he had no kids he worked from home and
sure we had two kids who weren't
involved with Mike but my kids don't
matter because
I want to get my rocks off and then they
they decided to have a small bedroom on
the first floor because it was more
private the idea is that Rob and I would
keep the master bedroom and I could go
downstairs and sleep with Mike when I
wanted to
honestly Rob is always preferred to
sleep alone I was happy to have the bed
to himself because Rob as we have
mentioned before is a doof okay and then
they the the best part of this was the
very end it turns out that they are
thinking about divorce shocker
shocker he says Mike and I love this
living together work really well for us
for four years recently Rob decided it
was time for him to get his own
apartment mostly because he wants a
little more autonomy even though he
lives right nearby and comes over for
dinner most nights so we decided to
divorce
oh is that what happened I can't believe
it
no shocker it turns out that when you
told your four and eight-year-olds that
you can love more than one person at a
time
you couldn't sure I quit wow that was
not predictable in any way that you
would get divorced after having sex with
another dude and bring him into your
house couldn't what I'm just my mind
blown
unreal he says people might point to
that and say oh so I guess non-monogamy
didn't work in the end I guess it ruined
your marriage or do they think poor Rob
but Rob dates he has a life he fully
enjoys and chose he's about to turn 50
he wanted to feel what it was like to
steer his own ship for a while to have a
little more space and that's what he has
Mike and I are gonna get married soon
I think people assume that now we'll be
monogamous since our relationship is so
romantic
but nope we have no interest in a
marriage that doesn't provide a space to
express and act on attractions to other
people and to continue to change and
grow in a funny way been given the
statistics around infidelity I think
we're a lot more committed to
non-monogamy than most monogamous people
aren't monogamy no statistically
speaking this is false you are 100%
committed to non-monogamy and the
majority of monogamous people are
committed to monogamy and so you ruin
your life and you ruin your children's
life and you're on your husband's life
so well done all because you weren't
sexually compatible which really means
that you weren't willing to be giving in
the bedroom or your husband wasn't any
wouldn't talk about it so well done lady
these people put their kids last make me
sick make me sick the kids in this they
don't even come into the picture it's
all about just how you feel in the
bedroom
well if you gonna do that don't have
kids in the first place really if you
want to live that lifestyle live that
lifestyle don't eff up your kids
ridiculous okay time for a quick
Federalist paper so Federalist number 33
from the from the ridiculous to the
sublime Federalist number 33 Alexander
Hamilton continues to
the federal taxing power so he's talking
in the Constitution about the fact they
get to tax at the federal level a lot of
people were afraid this would lead to
the federal government becoming
overbearing and encroaching which
happened okay so he begins by discussing
the so-called Necessary and Proper
Clause this is the clause of the
Constitution that says that the federal
government has the power to make all
laws necessary and proper for carrying
into execution the powers by the
Constitution vested in the government of
the United States in other words if
there's a power in the Constitution then
the federal government can pass a law to
effectuate that power and here's what
Hamilton says he says what is a power
but the ability or faculty of doing a
thing what is the ability to do a thing
but the power of employing the means
necessary to its execution
what is a legislative power but a power
of making laws what are the mean sexy
could have legislative power but laws
what is the power of laying and
collecting taxes but a legislative power
or power of making laws to lay and
collect taxes in other words when it
says Necessary and Proper if I say you
have the power to legislators the power
to regulate interstate commerce that
means it has the power to pass laws and
create agencies to effectuate those laws
right everybody agrees with this
Hamilton says the point of this clause
is to restrict the power of the federal
government to only that which is
necessary so otherwise you would just
say the government has power to do
whatever it wants instead it says the
power the government has the power to
regulate interstate commerce for example
and then it says the government has the
power to do what is necessary and proper
to accomplish those those effects right
now here's the problem
Hamilton is totally right about this but
the Supreme Court decided that the
Necessary and Proper Clause was not
actually the Necessary and Proper Clause
that was the government should be able
to do whatever it wants Clause it's a
serious problem so there's a landmark
decision by Chief Justice John Marshall
in McCulloch versus Maryland he decided
wrongly that it was the the Necessary
and Proper Clause was used as the
justification for the creation of a
National Bank so the state of Maryland
had attempted to impede the operations
of the second bank of the United States
by taxing out-of-state banks the second
bank of the United States was the only
out-of-state bank the court ruled
against Maryland and Justice John
Marshall said that the Constitution
didn't give Congress the permission to
create a federal bank but it gave
Congress the implied power to do so
under the Necessary and Proper Clause so
Congress could realize or fulfill its
expressed taxing and spending powers
this is a wrongly decided case Necessary
and Proper means necessary
not wanted necessary was it absolutely
necessary for there to be a bank of the
United States to tax and spend no we
haven't had a Bank of the United States
for a century and a half in the United
States and we've been able to tax and
spend pretty well so this was not true
did the worries about the Necessary and
Proper Clause were well-founded but it's
not clear that without the Necessary and
Proper Clause the Supreme Court would
have done the same thing okay so we will
be back here tomorrow with all of the
latest I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018